The Economist Intelligence Unit
democracy index seeks to measure the
health of democracy in pretty much all
the countries around the world it breaks
this down into five categories the
electoral process the functioning of
government civil liberties political
participation and political culture the
scores range from Norway which we rate
as the most democratic country on earth
all the way down to North Korea a
hereditary communist monarchy which is
by far the least although the world has
obviously gotten a lot more democratic
over the past century in the past thirty
years since the end of the Cold War
since the EIU started measuring it which
was in 2006 things appear to have
regressed somewhat today roughly half
the world's people live in some form of
democracy but by our rather strict
measurements only about five percent
live in what we call a full democracy
and a good third also live in solid
authoritarian regimes with a big portion
of that in China one of the less gloomy
findings is the political participation
seems to be up this is probably related
to a widespread feeling in a lot of
countries that democracy is under threat
that the threats of fake news subversion
by foreign powers such as Russia and the
rise of authoritarian leaders from
Hungary to Poland to all kinds of places
means that people can't take democracy
for granted anymore
and so you see a lot more people
demonstrating in the streets getting out
to vote and organizing online
the most improved indicator was to do
with women's participation in politics
partly that reflects a genuine
improvement in the status of women and
the increased likelihood that voters are
prepared to vote for them alas it also
represents a certain amount of gaming
the system particularly by authoritarian
regimes Rwanda for example has a
majority female parliament which sounds
great until you realize that the
parliament has no power whatsoever and
the president is very much
male it might seem like a paradox that
even as democracy retreats around the
world political participation has gone
up but it's not it's a reaction against
the fact that more and more people are
aware that they are in danger of losing
some of their democratic freedoms and
they're not prepared to take that lying
down they're getting out there they're
voting more they're organizing online
and sometimes they're demonstrating in
the streets
the biggest election in 2019 will be in
India as always it will be the biggest
election held anywhere ever the fact
that we don't know who's going to win
maybe the incumbent party maybe the
opposition give you a sense that it
really will represent roughly the will
of a billion people another big one to
watch is Nigeria that will be incredibly
corrupt and quite a few people will get
killed but it's worth remembering that
only a couple of decades ago in Nigeria
was the dictatorship that's not true
anymore and despite the absence of a
dictator Nigeria has held together
despite all predictions it's another
fine example in fact of how democracy
does have the ability to hold disparate
countries together because it reflects
the will of the actual voters and a
final big election to watch is for the
European Parliament here we don't even
know which countries are going to
participate because we don't know
whether Britain's going to be part of it
or not so all eyes are going to be
watching will the European Union hold
together will the rise of the populist
and the Nationalists continue and my
guess is that actually they've peaked
and this could be the start of their
retreat